Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde",
"Histoire et mémoire
d'en France :
"sur les traces
de François Mauriac".
Il a traversé le siècle dernier
comme un prince
de la littérature
et a ciselé l'actualité
à travers son bloc-notes,
décryptant l'histoire
en train de se faire,
celle de la France
à travers lui.
Ecrivain catholique,
tel il s'éprouvait
au-dedans de son intimité,
mais avec la liberté
de publier
"des livres
à damner les saints",
selon l'expression
de Roger Martin du Gard.
Venu d'un milieu
provincial, conformiste,
bourgeois et nationaliste,
il brilla dans le salon littéraire
de l'entre-deux-guerres,
fréquenta les milieux
nationalistes,
avant d'exécrer
la puanteur de l'extrême droite
xénophobe.
Il publia même
un "cahier noir"
de la collaboration pétainiste,
dénonça le colonialisme
en témoin du Christ,
et devint le chantre
d'un gaullisme d'espérance,
auquel il se montra
d'une fidélité ardente.
Son oeuvre littéraire
est une mémoire vivant
de sentiments et d'événements
portés par des personnages tiraillés
par des passions extrêmes.
A travers François Mauriac,
c'est bien de l'histoire
et de la mémoire d'en France
dont il sera question.
S'il collectionna
sa vie durant
les best-sellers,
les récompenses
et les honneurs,
un mépris, aussi,
de l'extrême droite,
il y avait
chez François Mauriac
une forme de rébellion intime
à l'égard des siens,
une pudeur charnelle
"qui le brûla
jusqu'à l'épuisement",
selon son fils,
Claude Mauriac,
et une créativité littéraire
a toujours fécondé, entre romans,
témoignages et poésie.
Nous allons découvrir
cet arpenteur littéraire
et politique
de la France passée,
contemporaine aussi,
avec mes invités
que je vous présente.
Bernard Cazeneuve,
vous êtes avocat,
ancien Premier ministre
et vous venez de consacrer
un essai à François Mauriac.
Florence Delay,
vous êtes écrivaine
de l'Académie française.
On dit bien "écrivaine"
pour l'Académie française ?
-Personnellement,
je préfère le neutre.
-Alors donc,
écrivain
de l'Académie française.
Raphaël Gaillard,
vous êtes psychiatre
et essayiste.
Alors, avant de parler politique,
abordant le Mauriac
intime, mystérieux,
scrutant l'âme humaine,
la violence
et la noirceur des passions,
et dont vous dites,
Bernard Cazeneuve, dans votre livre,
que vous y avez cherché
le reflet
de votre propre existence.
Cherché quoi ?
Un éclaireur ?
Un maître ? Un guide ?
Ou plus simplement,
êtes-vous à la recherche
d'un roman familial ?
-Je n'ai pas cherché,
dans la noirceur des âmes
des personnages de Mauriac,
le reflet de ma propre existence.
J'ai voulu dire que la lecture
est une occasion pour chacun,
comme l'écriture, d'ailleurs,
de livrer une partie de soi-même.
A chaque fois qu'on lit un roman,
ou souvent,
étant jeune,
lorsque je lisais un roman,
je cherchais à éprouver
des sensations,
des émotions,
qui appartenaient
à mon intimité, mon histoire.
Ce qui m'a frappé chez Mauriac,
c'est que la lecture
du "Noeud de vipères",
et des romans
qui ont suivi,
m'a fait entrer
immédiatement dans l'âge adulte,
alors même que je n'avais
que 9 ans et que j'étais
dans les romans d'aventures
de Jules Verne
et les belles illustrations
de Gustave Doré.
-Raymond Aron
avait coutume de dire
qu'on apprenait beaucoup
des gens illustres,
quelquefois,
de qui on était très différent.
Et il apprenait beaucoup plus
de Marx que de Tocqueville,
bien qu'il se sentait
plus proche de Tocqueville.
Entre la famille de Mauriac
et votre propre famille...
il y a quelque chose qui parle ?
-Tout est différent.
Mauriac, ce sont
les grandes propriétés
de la lande girondine.
C'est une famille installée
depuis très longtemps
dans la bourgeoisie,
qui n'a jamais rencontré
de difficultés matérielles.
Moi, je viens d'une famille
déracinée, qui n'avait rien,
qui a dû quitter
le pays qui était
son seul patrimoine,
dont le soleil et le ciel
étaient le seul patrimoine,
l'Algérie,
qui s'est retrouvée, en 1962,
en métropole
comme on disait, sans rien,
en ayant tout perdu,
puisque la seule chose
qu'ils avaient en possession,
c'était
les paysages,
les paysages de Tipaza,
les paysages d'Oran
qui ont marqué...
-Qui valent bien
ceux de Bordeaux.
-Oui,
mais c'était leur seul patrimoine,
leur patrimoine
était immatériel.
C'était une famille
qui avait des convictions
à l'opposé de celles
de la famille de Mauriac,
une famille laïque
et une famille militante
ancrée à gauche.
C'était le cas de mon père
et de ma mère.
L'univers
dans lequel j'ai vécu,
j'ai été élevé,
est un univers
absolument différent
de celui
de Mauriac, mais en même temps,
lorsque je découvre
Mauriac, ses personnages
et plus tard, "Le bloc-notes",
je vois un écrivain qui a,
comme il le disait lui-même
de son écriture, une pointe,
et qui, à travers l'écriture,
à travers la réflexion,
à travers la construction
complexe de sa personnalité,
cherche à s'affranchir
en permanence
de son propre milieu
par amour de la liberté.
Et lorsque celui
qui critiquait
la religion espagnole
de sa mère,
c'est-à-dire une conception
traditionaliste, fermée,
conservatrice du catholicisme,
s'en prend au clergé
catholique,
français et espagnol,
au moment de la guerre d'Espagne,
pour défendre
les républicains espagnols,
il affiche une grande liberté.
De la même manière,
quand il quitte
Le Figaro pour L'Express
pour défendre la cause
de ceux qui s'engagent
contre la colonisation,
il témoigne
de la même liberté d'esprit
et j'ai aimé voir
cette liberté s'exercer,
cet homme s'affranchir
de son milieu
pour dire, finalement,
sur les sujets
les plus importants
de son époque,
quelle était la juste position.
Je trouve qu'il y a,
pour quelqu'un qui s'intéresse
à la politique,
il m'est arrivé de m'y intéresser,
comme vous le savez,
il y a là quelque chose
qui ressemble
à un exercice de liberté,
de libre conscience
et de recherche
de la vérité.
-Florence Delay,
c'est habituel, comme ça,
de chercher,
à travers l'itinéraire
d'un écrivain...
sa propre histoire ?
-Personnellement,
j'ai toujours aimé copier,
C'est ce que j'ai enseigné
à mes étudiants,
que pour faire des progrès,
il fallait copier
les gens qu'on admirait.
Je n'ai jamais copié Mauriac,
ni essayé.
-Vous avez copié qui ?
-Qui j'ai copié ?
-Oui.
-J'ai copié Marguerite de Navarre,
qui était la soeur de François Ier,
j'ai copié
Ramon Gomez de la Serna...
Mais enfin,
ce n'est pas le sujet.
Ce que j'aimerais dire
tout de suite,
c'est que je pense
qu'on a du mal
avec les écrivains
qu'admirent vos parents.
Vous, Bernard Cazeneuve,
on n'a pas l'impression
qu'ils soient...
qu'ils soient
des modèles de lecteurs.
De par votre...
votre... la description
que vous donnez de vos débuts.
Moi, je suis née
dans une bibliothèque
et Mauriac était l'écrivain...
Un écrivain très cher à mon père.
-Je rappelle que votre père
était Jean Delay
et qu'il était
professeur de psychiatrie.
-C'est ça.
Mon père a été élu,
comme Mauriac,
à l'Académie française,
ce qui,
entre parenthèses...
Quand Bernard Cazeneuve évoque
ses lectures d'enfant,
il rappelle qu'il a lu
par hasard "Noeud de vipères"
de Mauriac...
à neuf ans,
ce qui est épouvantable,
quand on y songe.
Mais il croyait qu'il s'agissait
de vraies vipères
et ils avaient très peur
des vipères.
Et cette histoire m'a frappée
et j'ai fait la coïncidence
avec la parution
de "Noeuds de vipères"
de Mauriac, en 1932,
et son élection
à l'Académie française
en 33.
-Ah oui.
-Et il a mis
des vipères sur son épée.
Donc, c'est pour vous dire
que ce livre a vraiment
une histoire,
une histoire grossière.
Bref, il était un ami
de mon père.
Mon père l'a admiré au début.
Il a été un écrivain modèle
pour mon père modèle.
Modèle...
parce qu'il s'en prenait
à la province.
Au fond, mon père était aussi
un provincial.
Il était bâillonné...
-C'est les provinciaux
qui ont réussi à Paris.
-C'est ça.
"Qui sont montés",
comme on dit dans le sud-ouest.
"Ils sont montés à Paris."
Et là, ils ont...
Ils ont franchi une étape.
Mais personnellement,
Mauriac
n'a pas beaucoup compté.
"Le bloc-notes" a compté.
-On va en parler,
vous allez voir.
Raphaël Gaillard
à ce stade, là,
vous, c'est quelle madeleine
littéraire
qui a déclenché quelque chose
au départ, chez vous ?
Mauriac ou quelqu'un d'autre ?
-Oui, personnellement,
ce serait probablement Balzac,
mais ce que je trouve
très important, là,
dans ce que nous disons
de Mauriac,
ce n'est peut-être pas tant
Mauriac
que le Mauriac
de Bernard Cazeneuve,
et ce chemin
de Bernard Cazeneuve
vers Mauriac.
Je trouve
que même dans l'écriture,
on a l'impression
de trouver un écho
à l'écriture de Mauriac,
en y trouvant l'écriture
de Bernard Cazeneuve.
On y reconnaît
son éloquence
et une autre écriture,
une écriture très tenue,
une très belle écriture,
et cette impression que,
en parlant de Mauriac,
dans cette belle collection,
d'ailleurs,
"Ma vie avec",
il s'agit de parler
d'un apprentissage,
de la façon
dont un enfant construit
son identité au travers
de ses lectures,
y compris à l'extérieur
de ses repères,
de ses repères familiaux,
et comment se tisse,
dans l'écriture telle
que nous la retrouvons aujourd'hui,
l'identité d'un homme
et l'identité
que nous partageons ici...
-Mais justement, à ce stade-là,
Bernard Cazeneuve,
est-ce que ce n'est pas inhabituel
aujourd'hui,
pour un homme politique,
de se présenter,
j'allais dire,
avec un blason littéraire ?
Je me souviens,
en tant que journaliste
politique,
qu'avec certains
hommes politiques
qui avaient de la culture,
- je pense à Laurent Fabius
et à Alain Juppé -
ils ont même essayé
de cacher un peu
leur côté littéraire
pour faire peuple.
Vous, vous essayez...
Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
un côté un peu rétro,
là, d'apparaître
aujourd'hui,
surtout dans le climat social
de la France,
avec ce blason-là ?
-Mais pourquoi voulez-vous
que je me préoccupe de ces sujets ?
Pourquoi voulez-vous
que je m'occupe
lorsque j'ai quelque chose
à dire ou à écrire,
de savoir
quel est l'air du temps ?
Pourquoi faudrait-il toujours,
quand on exerce
une responsabilité publique
ou qu'on en a exercé une,
se poser la question
de savoir si ce que l'on va faire
va plaire ou déplaire
en se privant de la possibilité
d'apparaître
comme on est profondément,
sincèrement.
Je ne raisonne pas
de cette manière-là.
Je fais ce que j'estime
devoir faire quand j'en ai envie,
en fonction de ce que me dicte
ma conscience,
avec une liberté totale.
Et si ensuite,
les meutes des réseaux sociaux
ou les commentaires
vont dans une direction
plutôt que dans une autre,
c'est l'affaire de ceux
qui commandent, la mienne.
On doit quand même,
quand on est dans la vie publique
et qu'on a une parole publique,
pouvoir de temps en temps
témoigner de sa liberté
et s'affranchir
des contraintes
de l'époque.
Vos questions sont très légitimes.
Mais ce sont des questions
de journaliste.
-Oui, mais...
Vous avez conscience
qu'on va un peu
à contre-courant de l'esprit
du temps ?
-Vous avez vu le nombre de ceux
qui déploient
une énergie considérable
pour être sûrs d'être
dans le courant dominant,
dans la masse grégaire
de ceux qui vont toujours
dans la même direction
avec pour seule
et unique obsession
d'augmenter leur nombre
de followers ?
Ce n'est pas ma préoccupation.
-Il y a quelques années,
je faisais écrire
Marthe Robert,
la critique littéraire,
dans une revue
que je dirige toujours,
Passages, dans une chronique
qui s'appelait
"Chronique du présent obscur".
Vous auriez pu signer
une chronique comme celle-là ?
Qui, à l'époque,
avait impressionné
le ministère de la Culture,
en considérant qu'aujourd'hui,
tout ce qui est instantané,
présent, etc.,
occupe toute la scène
et on manque de recul,
en quelque sorte.
-Moi, j'ai été très marqué
par la lecture de cet auteur,
comme la lecture
de bien d'autres auteurs :
Tchekhov, Camus, Balzac...
J'aurais pu écrire
d'autres livres
et peut-être le ferai-je
dans les années qui viennent,
et peut-être écrirai-je
moi-même
des ouvrages littéraires
qui n'évoqueront la mémoire
d'aucun de ces personnages
immenses.
Mais ce que je fais,
je le fais simplement
en sincérité, et je le fais
parce que dans la période
dans laquelle nous vivons,
un homme qui résiste
à son époque,
qui se détache de son milieu,
qui sait que l'époque
dans laquelle il vit
est une époque
où on s'intéresse moins
à ce que disent
ceux qui s'expriment
qu'à l'endroit d'où ils parlent,
accepte de s'affranchir
de toutes les contraintes
et des entraves de son milieu
pour qu'on l'écoute enfin,
pour qu'on s'intéresse davantage
à ce qu'il dit
qu'à l'endroit d'où il parle.
Et il fait pour cela
bien des choses courageuses
qui le mettent en orthogonalité
par rapport à son milieu.
Je trouve ça extrêmement courageux.
On pouvait s'attendre
à ce que Mauriac
prenne une autre position
sur la guerre d'Espagne.
On aurait pu imaginer
qu'il aurait été davantage
dans le courant maurrassien
qu'adhérant
au Sillon de Marc Sangnier.
On aurait pu
imaginer qu'il ait pu
tenir des propos
beaucoup plus amènes
vis-à-vis de l'Eglise catholique
et de son comportement,
au moment de l'affaire Dreyfus.
Sa famille
était antidreyfusarde.
Mais il y a un oncle,
qui a inspiré
"Le mystère Frontenac",
qui est le frère de son père,
qui est un libre penseur.
Son père, d'ailleurs, était...
Il n'était pas catholique.
Tous les vendredis,
il avalait une côtelette
devant son épouse
pour bien montrer
la distance qu'il avait
avec la religion.
Donc, c'est un homme
qui, durant toute sa vie,
y compris en restant fidèle
à ses convictions religieuses,
au message universel
du Christ,
prend à l'égard des églises,
des institutions qui verrouillent,
qui cadenassent
et des observateurs
autoproclamés
et dont le jugement
est toujours prompt
et pas toujours pertinent,
il prend,
à l'égard de tous ces acteurs,
une liberté totale qui témoigne
d'une audace absolue.
Et c'est pour rendre hommage à cela
que j'ai fait ce livre.
-Raphaël Gaillard,
qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de cet affranchissement
cazeneuvien,
si on peut dire,
par rapport au temps,
à l'époque, aux personnages...
-Sur les temps présents,
je suis pas sûr d'être compétent,
mais sur la dynamique
d'un homme...
Et vous avez fait référence
et à Marthe Robert,
et au roman familial.
Elle a beaucoup écrit
sur cette question
du roman familial
comme à l'origine du roman,
origine du roman
et roman des origines....
Et je trouve
que c'est une idée
très intéressante,
qui part
d'une construction
de la psychanalyse,
selon laquelle l'enfant,
à un moment donné
de son développement,
va sortir de l'horizon familial
pour définir, choisir
des figures d'identification
au-delà, y compris d'ailleurs
dans le fantasme
qu'il puisse être lui-même
l'enfant d'un autre,
enfant trouvé,
enfant adopté,
rejeton d'une autre famille,
etc.
Et cette dynamique
du roman familial,
que tout enfant traverse,
elle trouve
une autre nature
au moment de la lecture.
Je ne suis pas sûr
que même Marthe Robert,
qui était très fine,
ait beaucoup dit...
Dans ces années clés,
dans ces années dites
de la période de latence
entre 8 et 12 ans,
où on découvre la littérature,
se dessine par la littérature
un intérêt qui sera marquant
sur toute l'existence.
Et c'est, cette fois,
pas tant se penser
issu d'une autre filiation,
mais c'est réellement
s'inscrire
dans une autre filiation
qui est la filiation littéraire.
Et je trouve passionnant
de voir,
chez tout un chacun,
la façon dont la lecture,
à cet âge,
comme vous le racontez,
à neuf ans,
devient déterminante
sur le cadre de pensée...
et pas seulement
le cadre de pensée, sur le...
Je dirais,
presque, la texture
de la personnalité
dans tout le devenir
d'une personne
et on le sent très bien.
C'est pour ça que je pointais
que c'est votre Mauriac
parce qu'on sent comment se tisse
votre personnalité
et cette lecture,
et d'autres lectures,
parce qu'effectivement,
on en devine
beaucoup d'autres,
qui sont, je pense,
le cheminement d'une personne.
Donc, sur les temps présents,
je ne saurais pas dire,
mais je pointe en psychiatre
que cette dynamique
de la lecture et la façon
dont elle contribue
à construire une personnalité,
y compris en dehors
de ses repères
et bien au-delà,
bien au-delà
de ses repères familiaux,
elle est constitutive
et extrêmement importante
pour les individus
que nous sommes.
-Il y a...
-Je vous en prie.
-Juste un petit mot.
Je dois avouer que ce livre,
je l'ai écrit en même temps
- c'est le mystère et le hasard
des correspondances
et des rencontres -
que j'achevais la lecture
des deux tomes
de "La jeunesse d'André Gide",
de Jean Delay,
c'est-à-dire la construction
de la personnalité
d'André Gide dans l'enfance,
racontée par le prédécesseur
de Raphaël Gaillard
à Sainte-Anne,
grand psychiatre, grand...
grand érudit,
homme de lettres...
Et j'ai été très frappé
par les deux tomes
de "La jeunesse d'André Gide"
parce que...
Ca se lit comme un roman
et on voit le processus
que vous venez de décrire
très cliniquement, presque,
de construction
de la personnalité
à travers les épreuves
et les étapes de la jeunesse.
Et lorsque je me mets à faire
ce livre sur Mauriac,
pendant le confinement,
je viens d'achever la lecture
de "La jeunesse d'André Gide"
de Jean Delay.
J'étais très impressionné
par la somme,
l'intensité de cette somme
que constituent ces deux tomes.
Et, bien entendu,
ça éveille en moi
beaucoup de questionnements
sur ce qu'est l'enfance
et la jeunesse
dans le processus de construction
de chaque individu,
à travers la rencontre
avec la nature,
les épreuves familiales,
les drames
que peuvent rencontrer les familles.
En l'occurrence,
Gide perdra son père
très jeune.
-Oui.
-Comme Mauriac.
Toutes ces épreuves auront contribué
à façonner les personnalités.
-Bernard Cazeneuve,
vous évoquez André Gide.
André Gide disait
de François Mauriac
que, sur la question de la chair,
il avait beaucoup de chaînes.
Sur cette question...
-Et Mauriac disait de Gide
qu'il avait trop cassé les chaînes
qui l'unissaient à la religion.
Ils avaient quelques contentieux
l'un avec l'autre.
-Ils avaient quelques contentieux.
Il n'y a pas cette transgression
chez Mauriac.
On a l'impression
qu'il n'y va pas clairement.
Gide n'a pas, par exemple,
hésité à...
à apparaître comme homosexuel,
tout en étant
un très grand écrivain.
-C'est ce que n'a pas voulu
François Mauriac.
Il n'a pas voulu apparaître ainsi.
Le rapprochement
entre Gide et Mauriac,
c'est aussi des mères
excessivement puritaines,
un milieu corseté
qu'a fait exploser Gide
et que n'a pas fait exploser
Mauriac.
Parce que Mauriac
s'est attaché,
comme Gide, d'ailleurs,
au réel,
avec la même passion du réel
et la même acuité de romancier.
Il l'a appliquée
aux hommes politiques
et à son analyse.
C'est important,
ce que vous dites de la jeunesse,
parce que mon père pensait
que la jeunesse
et la genèse d'un écrivain...
-Très intéressant.
-...que c'est là
qu'il se constitue.
Il joue sur les mots
"jeunesse" et "genèse".
-Et alors ?
-Donc quand Raphaël Gaillard évoque
le stade du miroir,
où l'enfant
se dédouble enfin,
et que,
pour Bernard Cazeneuve,
c'est le noeud de vipères,
on est quand même très frappé.
-Moi, je voudrais
vous interroger à tous les trois,
l'enfant Cazeneuve,
l'enfant Delay et l'enfant Gaillard,
sur ce noeud familial.
Parce que, je vais vous dire,
il est, François Mauriac,
d'une fidélité contrariée
par rapport à sa famille,
avec quelques silences
sur son histoire.
Tandis qu'en prenant
un grand écrivain
comme Thomas Bernhard,
dans "Extinction",
il considère
qu'il faut mettre de côté
sa famille.
Annie Ernaux dit qu'on écrit
pour venger sa race.
Par rapport à cette question
des origines, chacun de vous...
Bernard Cazeneuve,
vous, vous pensez qu'on écrit
pour venger sa race,
pour l'éteindre,
pour la prolonger ?
On le fait pour quoi, finalement ?
C'est un débat important,
aujourd'hui.
-J'ai une conviction,
dont je ne parviens pas
à éclairer
la source
ou, en tous les cas,
le sens qu'elle révèle :
la mémoire des morts préside
à l'action des vivants.
J'ai trop de relations
avec des êtres que je n'ai
jamais connus,
et y compris
de ma propre famille,
pour ne pas, finalement, me dire
que Mitterrand avait raison,
quand il croyait
"aux forces de l'esprit."
Donc moi, j'écris pour que les fils
ne se rompent pas,
pour que les fils d'une histoire
familiale qui vient de loin
et qui concerne beaucoup d'êtres
qu'on n'a pas connus
et d'autres
qui n'appartenaient pas
à la famille
au sens génétique du terme,
mais qui peuvent appartenir
à la famille de pensée
ou de connivence,
que ces fils-là ne se rompent pas.
Donc ce qui me surprend beaucoup,
et avec l'âge qui avance,
de plus en plus,
c'est
les connexions,
les correspondances,
qui peuvent se nouer,
à un moment ou un autre,
avec des personnages
qu'on n'a jamais rencontrés,
qu'on ne rencontrera jamais
et dont on a par ailleurs
une connaissance intime
et très mystérieuse.
Et parfois,
l'écriture permet d'essayer,
malgré soi ou en dépit de soi-même,
de restituer
ce que sont ces fils
et de comprendre
comment ils se sont
constitués peu à peu,
malgré soi
ou en dépit de soi-même.
-Oui. Florence,
là-dessus ?
Parce que c'est écrire
pour faire revivre ses morts,
pour retrouver... ?
-Je vais revenir
à votre question préalable
sur l'enfance.
J'ai eu une grande chance :
j'ai eu une enfance heureuse.
J'ai eu un père aimant,
une mère etc.,
qui étaient grands lecteurs,
qui avaient des passions de lecture
et, d'une certaine façon,
l'immensité du paysage littéraire
avait la grandeur
de l'appartement familial,
la bibliothèque de chacun,
la bibliothèque de ma mère,
de mon père,
et je pense que j'ai vécu
parmi les livres
comme parmi des plantes,
comme parmi un jardin,
donc j'ai tout de suite aimé
les livres
et j'ai tout de suite souhaité
faire et essayer
d'être écrivain.
Mais pas écrivain pour écrire,
écrivain de...
Pas pour célébrer
les morts...
-Vous êtes
le scribe des origines ?
-...mais pour célébrer.
Je ne savais pas encore quoi.
Célébrer mon éducation, d'abord.
Mon premier livre
a été un roman d'éducation,
qui s'appelait
"Minuit sur les jeux",
où, grâce au bonheur
qui fut le mien,
j'arrivais à me moquer
de moi-même
et à décrire l'éducation
d'une jeune bourgeoise.
D'ailleurs, le livre s'appelait
"La bourgeoise surnaturelle",
mais Gallimard trouvait
que ça ressemblait trop
à "Rêveuse bourgeoisie",
alors on m'a obligée d'en changer.
-Raphaël Gaillard,
sur ce thème-là, important,
venger sa race... ?
-J'ai parlé
de tissage par la lecture,
et Bernard Cazeneuve évoquait
les fils qui ne devraient pas
se rompre.
Nous sommes donc
dans cette métaphore du tissage,
que nous pourrions poursuivre
par le métissage,
ce qui soulignera mon ambivalence
quant à ce propos sur la race
et la vengeance.
Je crois que...
Plutôt que...
Plutôt que cette violence,
il est intéressant de voir
comment peuvent s'hybrider
des univers différents,
par l'écriture,
si c'est l'écriture,
mais, en amont de l'écriture,
par la lecture.
Parce que lire, c'est déjà,
d'une certaine façon, écrire.
C'est déjà être
dans un processus d'écriture,
que d'être lecteur.
Et ce chemin
de la lecture,
c'est pas du tout un chemin neutre,
c'est pas un chemin
qui laisse le lecteur de côté
où en regard de son livre.
Celui qui clôt le livre,
c'est le lecteur.
Et ce chemin-là,
effectivement, il fait circuler
des générations différentes,
il tisse des histoires différentes
et il dessine une identité.
Je trouve
que ce cheminement,
ces cheminements qui,
c'est vrai,
supposent un temps long...
Ces cheminements
supposent un temps long
et sont extrêmement intéressants
pour comprendre
la complexité,
la richesse d'une personnalité.
Dans mon métier de psychiatre,
ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est la substance
d'une personnalité,
c'est l'étoffe d'une personnalité,
c'est toute la complexité,
les faux-semblants,
les clairs-obscurs.
C'est pas la grande lumière,
c'est pas le blanc et le noir,
c'est quelque chose
qui procède du tissage
qui, je pense, bénéficie
de cet apprentissage par la lecture.
-On parle beaucoup de Mauriac,
mais on a parlé aussi
d'un certain Jean Delay.
Alors, Florence n'a pas besoin
d'en parler, si je puis dire,
puisque c'est son père.
Raphaël a pris la suite,
puisqu'il est chef
du pôle de psychiatrie
à Sainte-Anne,
où Jean Delay a officié.
Et vous, comment avez-vous trouvé ?
Qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à lire
Jean Delay,
qui est d'abord un psychiatre,
même si c'était
un homme de littérature ?
-Ce qui m'a amené à lire Jean Delay,
c'est une insomnie, en réalité.
Parce qu'un soir,
où j'étais totalement
dans l'impossibilité de m'endormir,
je suis allé sur le site de
l'Institut national de l'audiovisuel
pour regarder
une émission littéraire.
Je vois un personnage
apparaître dans cette émission
qui raconte
la jeunesse d'André Gide.
Je suis très impressionné
par la qualité de langue,
le niveau de précision du propos
et le sentiment, comment dirais-je,
de classe intellectuelle
qui se dégage du personnage.
Alors, je vais sur le site de l'INA
pour essayer de trouver
d'autres vidéos.
Et là, je trouve
une longue interview,
faite par un diplomate
qui avait de l'intérêt
pour la littérature,
monsieur Bouhadef, de Jean Delay.
Je vois une conversation
se nouer
entre l'intervieweur
et l'écrivain,
où l'écrivain,
avec énormément d'humilité,
de gentillesse...
Une grande gentillesse
se dégage
de la personnalité
de Jean Delay.
Il y a une profonde altérité,
pour être plus précis.
Il corrige, à la marge,
l'intervieweur,
lorsque, sur une date,
il se trompe, sur un événement,
il est insuffisamment précis.
Et je suis fasciné
par ce personnage,
qui est à la fois
une encyclopédie vivante,
un amoureux des lettres,
un extraordinaire conteur...
Et donc je me plonge
dans ses écrits
pour essayer de comprendre
qui il est.
Et à mesure que j'avance
dans la découverte du personnage,
la fascination augmente.
Pour moi, c'est l'un des...
...des grands personnages
du siècle dernier,
un intellectuel complet,
qui a touché
à plusieurs disciplines
et les a maîtrisées toutes,
qui a été aussi
un homme dans son siècle,
puisque je crois qu'il a rencontré
beaucoup d'acteurs
du Paris de l'époque.
Il les a connus,
aimés, fréquentés,
et sans doute les a-t-il
aussi jugés, mais avec
ce caractère que j'ai décrit,
qui était plein de bienveillance.
Et puis alors,
ce que je ressens chez lui aussi
et qui m'intéresse beaucoup,
c'est l'extrême solitude
et exigence dans le travail,
c'est-à-dire
qu'on ne peut pas produire
une telle oeuvre dans une vie
sans avoir consacré toute sa vie
au travail.
C'est le contraire d'un affabulateur
ou d'un prestidigitateur.
C'est un homme d'une rigueur
intellectuelle et au travail
absolues.
Donc j'ai énormément d'admiration
pour Jean Delay.
Et je suis extrêmement ému
de faire cette émission
avec Florence.
-On rougit ou on rosit d'émotion,
quand on entend ça,
Florence Delay ?
-Euh, j'étais...
J'étais au courant
de la façon dont Bernard Cazeneuve
est tombé amoureux de mon père.
Ils rient.
J'étais au courant.
Ce que je voulais dire,
c'était :
quelle merveille,
d'entendre les voix,
de pouvoir avoir ce bonheur,
dans le siècle où on est,
de découvrir, par une voix,
une oeuvre.
Mais les livres fermés n'ont pas
de voix.
Dès qu'on les ouvre,
ils ont une voix,
donc il joue ce rôle aussi.
Vous entendez Corneille,
quand même,
quand vous le lisez.
On ne saura jamais
quelle est la voix de Corneille,
mais on l'entend.
C'est pas du tout la voix de Racine.
Et c'est merveilleux, de voir aussi,
dans la bibliothèque,
finalement, un orchestre
et l'existence de tant de voix,
dont nous allons
aimer certaines,
même chérir,
et dont nous allons détester
d'autres.
Et c'est très agréable,
de détester, aussi,
et de se prononcer
de façon un peu violente.
Et je crois
que cette violence
n'est étrangère
à aucun de nos trois.
Bien dissimulée, parfois.
Moi, je suis
d'une extrême courtoisie,
en apparence.
-Oui. Un mot là-dessus,
Raphaël Gaillard ?
Sur la mémoire
de Delay.
-Je suis toujours ému d'entendre
parler de Jean Delay,
qui est une figure tutélaire
pour moi-même
et mes collaborateurs à Sainte-Anne,
puisqu'il y a animé les travaux
de l'équipe,
dont j'ai la responsabilité,
avec cette exigence
dans tous les domaines,
que vous évoquez,
même sur l'invention...
Puisque Jean Delay était
un des pionniers, sinon le pionnier
de la psychopharmacologie,
avec l'invention
du premier neuroleptique,
la chlorpromazine,
qui a changé le visage
de ce qui était l'asile
et qui est devenu
l'hôpital psychiatrique.
Puis c'est devenu,
non un lieu d'enfermement,
mais un lieu de soins.
C'est donc quelque chose
qui a vraiment changé
la vie de millions
de personnes et...
et l'organisation des soins
au travers du monde entier.
Il disait à son collaborateur
Pierre Deniker :
"C'est une trouvaille,
"il faut aller plus loin."
C'est la même exigence
qui l'amenait à considérer
qu'il fallait aller au-delà
de cette trouvaille.
Et je trouve que cette exigence,
dans le champ
de la psychopharmacologie
ou dans la culture que vous évoquez
quant à la littérature,
c'est quelque chose, évidemment,
d'inspirant pour la psychiatrie.
-Alors, je voudrais
vous rappeler cette citation
de François Mauriac.
"Ce sang des communistes,
"des nationaux,
des chrétiens,
"des juifs, nous a tous baptisés
du même baptême
"dont le général de Gaulle demeure
au milieu de nous
"le symbole vivant."
C'est quasiment une déclaration...
d'amour.
De quoi est le nom,
cette passion gaulliste
et pourquoi...
Je pose cette question à vous tous.
Pourquoi en sommes-nous
si loin aujourd'hui ?
Avec cette société fragmentée,
populiste, narcissique,
etc.
Bernard Cazeneuve ?
-D'abord, dans la citation
que vous venez d'évoquer,
on comprend ce qui rattache Mauriac
au catholicisme,
c'est moins les institutions
et les Eglises
que le message universel
du Christ.
C'est cela que porte
cette citation.
Si Mauriac prendra les positions
qu'il prendra à l'égard
de son milieu
ou des Eglises, c'est précisément
parce que c'est, pour lui,
le message universel du Christ
qu'il faut retenir
de l'adhésion
à la chrétienté et au catholicisme.
Son gaullisme,
il n'est pas ce que l'on croit.
Le gaullisme de Mauriac
n'est pas une inconditionnalité
au général de Gaulle.
Il a rencontré très peu
le général et, à chaque fois,
ça s'est pas très bien passé.
Il le rencontre
pour la première fois
au moment de la Libération.
Il est reçu avec son fils
et le général de Gaulle
ne lui parle
que des postes vacants
à l'Académie française !
Florence Delay rit.
Lui est dans...
la mythification du héros
de la France libre,
il s'attend à évoquer avec lui
la grandeur de la France,
les projets politiques
de celui qui l'a libérée,
mais non,
le général de Gaulle compte
le nombre de sièges vacants
à l'Académie et interroge Mauriac
sur le fait de savoir si on peut
faire élire à tel siège,
telle personnalité ou telle autre.
Mauriac est très déçu
parce qu'il a l'impression
de rencontrer un homme politique.
Deuxième rencontre,
il va voir le général de Gaulle
pour sauver Brasillach
de la peine capitale.
Il est contre la peine de mort
comme chrétien,
il considère que Brasillach,
qui l'a détesté,
injurié, insulté,
est un auteur
et que la peine de mort est
une monstruosité.
Il va chez le général de Gaulle
essayer de sauver Brasillach.
Il sort de l'entretien
avec le général de Gaulle
en disant :
"J'ai rencontré un cormoran."
Le général de Gaulle
n'a rien laissé apparaître.
fait le RPF,
Mauriac s'agace sur le thème :
"Je pensais à ce grand héros
de la France libre,
le voilà qu'il se met à faire
des partis comme les politiciens
de la IVe."
Il ne le dit pas comme ça
mais c'est ce que ça signifie.
Et donc, Mauriac n'a pas eu du tout
la relation d'inconditionnalité
qu'on décrit au général.
Il a une admiration littéraire
et politique
pour le personnage,
cette admiration
résulte en grande partie
du regard féroce
qu'il porte sur la médiocrité
des personnages
de la IVe République.
Joseph Laniel,
présenté comme un personnage
dans lequel "il y a du lingot",
Bidault, accroché aux grilles
du Quai d'Orsay,
donc il y a 3 personnages
sous la IVe République
qui lui plaisent :
de Gaulle qui est hors-concours
pour des raisons historiques,
Mendès France, qui est l'homme
de la décolonisation
et du courage
et que Mauriac va soutenir
à L'Express avec beaucoup de force,
et Mitterrand parce qu'il y voit
un personnage totalement romanesque
et qu'il y a vraisemblablement
chez Mitterrand,
comme chez Mauriac,
le même environnement
de douces collines,
de fleuves qui coulent,
de bourgeoisie attachée
au catholicisme,
et surtout,
il y a chez Mauriac
le passage au 104
de la rue de Vaugirard.
Il a connu au 104 de la rue
de Vaugirard Robert lorrain,
qui est l'oncle
de François Mitterrand,
qui est mort subitement
à l'âge de 18 ans
à l'infirmerie du lycée Henri-IV.
Mauriac en a été frappé.
Il comprend que Mitterrand est allé
lui aussi au 104,
qu'il est le neveu de Robert Lorrain
et il donne à Mitterrand
une personnalité romanesque.
Il n'a pas aimé non plus
la manière dont il s'est comporté
avec Mitterrand
lors de l'affaire des fuites
car Mauriac n'était pas
de ces dénonciateurs qui...
-Oui, mais quand Mitterrand
ne soutenait pas
le général de Gaulle,
il était rossé,
quasiment,
par l'écriture du "Bloc-notes".
-Oui, d'accord, mais...
Mauriac a pu avoir avec Mitterrand
des désaccords.
Il a pu les exprimer.
Mitterrand était un peu vachard
aussi avec Mauriac lorsqu'il reprend
la formule de Claudel
évoquant Mauriac
et le qualifiant
du "meilleur de nos écrivains
régionalistes",
ce qui n'était pas,
chez François
Mitterrand, un compliment,
mais les deux hommes
se respectaient et s'estimaient.
Et Mauriac
voit en Mitterrand,
en de Gaulle et en Mendès,
pour des raisons différentes,
des personnalités éminentes
de la IVe République
parce qu'elles sont intrinsèquement
éminentes
et parce que tous les autres
sont des médiocres,
et que Mauriac l'a bien identifié,
et, avec la pointe qui caractérise
son écriture
dans le "Bloc-notes",
il administre une ordonnance
à chacun de ceux
dont il considère
qu'ils ne sont pas à la hauteur
de la situation.
-Cette passion gaulliste,
qu'est-ce qu'elle vous inspire,
Raphaël Gaillard ?
-Nous parlions de filiations.
Vous avez beaucoup parlé
de filiations,
celles que nous nous imaginons,
que nous pouvons nous construire,
la filiation bien réelle
de Florence Delay...
Et puis,
apparaît une autre figure
à laquelle se rattacher
en filiation : de Gaulle.
Et je crois qu'il est toujours
question de la même chose,
c'est-à-dire de définir
des jalons qui...
donnent une forme de temps long,
ou en tout cas de perspectives
qui ne sont pas les soubresauts
de l'histoire.
Et vous indiquez que...
Mauriac pouvait,
par moment,
"rosser", dites-vous,
Mitterrand...
Quant à de Gaulle,
il y a une sorte de...
fidélité et de constance...
dans le lien
qui procède, je crois,
de cette idée
qu'il y a des...
Il y a des choses
qui ne varient pas,
il y a des choses
qui tiennent.
Vous posez la question
des temps qui courent :
comment fonctionner
aujourd'hui sans ce type
de figure tutélaire ?
sans ce type de temps long,
sans cette possibilité
d'inscrire...
-Et même,
sans cette unité nationale
prônée par Mauriac.
-On ignore ce qui est la cause
et la conséquence...
-Oui, mais on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui,
les choses sont ébréchées
de tous les côtés.
-Ou pire encore,
qu'est attendu un homme
providentiel,
et que cet homme providentiel
rassemblerait
autour d'un repli
plutôt que de l'histoire
qui pourrait nous réunir.
-Qu'est-ce que vous pensez,
Florence Delay, de ça ?
-Aujourd'hui...
c'est profil bas.
Effectivement,
Mais je crois qu'il faut pas
se cantonner là parce que...
On finira par répéter
tout le temps la même chose,
à savoir que traverse
une période sinistre. Bon.
Mais la lumière
existe toujours.
Il est possible
que tout ça se relève.
Je voudrais dire deux choses.
Un, que...
Si de Gaulle est un modèle,
c'est parce qu'il a du courage.
Bon.
Il a eu du courage
dans une période... Bon.
Et le courage, Mauriac admire.
Bon.
Il ne faut pas oublier,
chez Mauriac,
la charité.
D'ailleurs,
Cazeneuve insiste là-dessus :
"justice et charité".
On pourrait dire : "Oui,
"mais alors, pourquoi est-il
si méchant ?"
Il est méchant par justice,
et au nom
de la vérité.
Et je trouve formidable
qu'un écrivain, un homme,
qui a commencé vraiment à droite,
se reversent vers les idées
dites de gauche à cause...
A cause de quoi ?
Eh bien ce qui a été, vraiment,
vital pour lui,
c'est l'attitude médiocre,
lamentable,
du clergé espagnol.
Quand il a vu comment se conduisait
l'Eglise, en Espagne,
par rapport aux républicains,
son coeur s'est révolté.
Et c'est...
formidable, parce que
là est le vrai chrétien.
dont on parlait.
Bon, maintenant,
pour aujourd'hui,
redressons-nous tous.
Commençons par nous-mêmes.
-Là-dessus,
Bernard Cazeneuve,
on est sur un point essentiel.
D'ailleurs,
dans votre livre,
vous le dites,
il ne s'est trompé
sur presque rien.
Or, aujourd'hui,
si vous prenez
les grands écrivains,
les grands médecins,
les grands ingénieurs,
les grands architectes, etc.,
c'est des prises de position
successives,
et il n'y a pas,
si je puis dire,
cette liberté, cette...
A quoi c'est dû ?
A la médiocrité
de la politique ?
Est-ce que vous pensez
que vous pouvez y remédier
avec ce que vous souhaitez
incarner aujourd'hui
pour la nation ?
-D'abord,
je pense pas du tout
que nous soyons sans écrivains,
sans intellectuels, sans médecins...
-On n'a pas dit
qu'on n'avait pas de...
-Non mais qui portent même
des idées courageuses,
qui les manifestent,
qui les matérialisent
et pour lesquelles
ils se mobilisent grandement.
Le problème est moins
parmi les intellectuels
que parmi les politiques,
et un peu aussi
la classe médiatique.
Si vous voulez,
quand les choses vont mal,
quand vous vivez une période
d'affaissement des institutions,
de sens des repères,
du sens de l'Etat
et du sens de la nation,
trouver dans le pays
le ressort du sursaut
ou du redressement,
il faut que ceux qui portent
une parole publique
aient d'abord une conviction
et une seule,
qu'avait le général de Gaulle,
et qu'avaient aussi
des personnalités
comme Pierre Mendès France.
C'est l'idée que la France
est plus grande qu'eux.
Ils ont été animés
tout au long de leur vie
par une idée simple,
c'était que la France était
infiniment plus grande
qu'ils ne l'étaient eux-mêmes
et que,
dès lors qu'ils décidaient
de la servir,
ils ne pouvaient la servir
que dans la plus grande abnégation.
Donc ça donne le départ
du général de Gaulle
avec son aide de camp,
sans sa famille,
à Londres, sans savoir
ce dont demain sera fait
et sans savoir si cet acte,
d'ailleurs, pour lui,
ne signifie pas
jusqu'à la renonciation
de pouvoir continuer à vivre,
à vivre libre,
mais il pose cet acte
parce qu'il pense
à un moment donné
que la France
est plus grande que lui
et que se mettre
au service de ce pays,
alors même qu'il a
une certaine idée de lui-même,
implique la plus grande abnégation,
et non pas la recherche
d'une position,
d'un avantage,
d'une lumière,
d'une gratification
ou d'un honneur, mais la recherche
de l'accomplissement du devoir
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'autre choix
que d'accomplir son devoir.
C'est ce que fait Mendès France
lorsqu'il décide
de partir quelques semaines
en se fixant lui-même
devant la représentation nationale
l'obligation de revenir en France
après avoir réglé
le problème de l'Indochine.
C'est ce que le général de Gaulle
se fixe pour agenda lui-même
lorsqu'il décide
d'engager la France
sur le chemin... enfin,
la résistance et la France libre
sur le chemin de la résistance
à tout prix,
en prenant tous les risques,
à l'occupant.
Donc pour moi,
la solution,
elle est dans la capacité
de chacun d'entre nous,
quel que soit son destin,
de se convaincre que la France
est plus grande que lui
et d'y consacrer la part d'énergie
qu'il peut y consacrer
pour faire en sorte
que la France continue.
Le général de Gaulle
avait une belle formule
qui devrait faire réfléchir
tous ceux qui se laissent aller
à la facilité
de l'ostracisation de l'autre
ou de la xénophobie.
De Gaulle disait :
"Est français
celui qui veut
"que la France continue."
"Est français celui qui veut
que la France continue."
Et donc, tous ceux
qui veulent
que la France continue
avec ses travers, son histoire,
sa capacité d'épopée,
et qui sont convaincus
qu'il faut que la France continue
parce qu'elle est plus grande
que nos vies
et que chacune
et chacun d'entre nous
doivent consacrer l'énergie
qui doit l'être
à son redressement.
-Comment vous ressentez ça,
Raphaël Gaillard ?
Est-ce qu'avant de vous raser,
vous vous dites
"La France est
plus grande que moi" ?
Est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il y a quelque chose
qui vient...
-C'est tendancieux,
comme question.
-Ah bah oui,
mais il faut bien poser
les questions,
fussent-elles
tendancieuses.
-Je trouve
que ça élargit la perspective,
et dans les mots que vous utilisez,
Bernard Cazeneuve,
il est question de ce qui est
plus grand que nous,
en l'occurrence la France,
et donc d'un destin collectif,
mais il est aussi question
de la façon dont il s'écrit,
dont il peut continuer,
et vous dites "épopée".
Je crois que la trame
est toujours la même, en fait.
La trame est celle
de la lecture, l'écriture.
Et cette continuité-là,
cette fois, vous l'exprimez
non à l'échelle individuelle,
celle qui vous a forgé,
de jeune lecteur
et de l'homme Bernard Cazeneuve
que vous êtes devenu,
mais de cette nation,
en tout cas
de cette communauté
qui vit d'histoire
et qui a tout avantage
à pouvoir en raconter
et pouvoir en écrire d'autres.
Je pense
que c'est très important
de pouvoir penser les choses
au-delà de l'homme providentiel.
D'ailleurs,
c'est aussi intéressant
que nous ne parlions pas
que de De Gaulle
mais aussi de Mendès France,
trop souvent éclipsé,
y compris dans notre échange.
Je pense qu'au-delà
de l'homme providentiel,
au-delà de la figure tutélaire,
celle-ci, pour la nation,
de De Gaulle,
il est question
de cette écriture commune
qui définit une trajectoire,
une histoire,
qui est une histoire dynamique,
qui est une histoire
qui doit continuer,
pour reprendre le mot de De Gaulle,
et à laquelle
nous nous employons donc,
et pas seulement avant de se raser,
chacun.
-Bernard Cazeneuve, j'ai envie
de vous poser une question
que tout le monde se pose.
Il y a un climat
un peu fiévreux
en France aujourd'hui.
La politique est très décriée,
nous avons vécu
une très longue crise sociale, etc.
Finalement,
qu'est-ce que vous apportez
et qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez apporter
à cette France
dont vous venez de parler
et à laquelle
vous voulez restituer
à la fois une grandeur,
une noblesse,
une solidarité, etc. ?
-Vous savez, moi,
je suis
un soixante-cinq-millionième
de la France.
-Mais pas que ça.
Vous avez une carrière politique.
-Certainement,
mais si l'on veut partager l'idée
avec le plus grand nombre
de nos concitoyens
que la France est plus grande
que chacune et chacun d'entre nous,
il faut commencer à restituer
le sens de l'action collective,
parce que la politique
est devenue
un exercice narcissisant,
individualiste,
et qui consiste, pour ceux
qui s'y livrent trop souvent,
à construire un parcours
pour eux-mêmes
sans se préoccuper de ce qu'est
le sens de la nation.
Donc si on veut être utile
aujourd'hui,
il faut contribuer,
par l'élaboration d'un projet,
par l'organisation
d'une force politique,
par le retour du sens
de l'action collective,
il faut contribuer
à donner une perspective au pays.
Le premier sujet,
c'est celui des valeurs
et des principes,
et notamment des valeurs
et des principes républicains.
Lorsque je vois qu'il y a
des forces politiques
qui expliquent
que les institutions
de la République
sont tournées
contre les citoyens
et qui essaient d'engendrer
au coeur du pays un sentiment
de relégation et de colère
à l'égard des institutions
de la République,
c'est "La police tue",
ce sont ces propos
qui sont diffusés
à l'encontre de ceux
qui représentent les institutions
et qui sont
systématiquement présentés
comme étant les artisans
d'un complot
ou d'une hostilité
à l'égard de leur propre peuple,
je me dis qu'on est loin
des principes républicains,
de la promesse républicaine
d'institutions
qui sont là
pour lutter
contre la discrimination,
contre la relégation,
contre toutes les formes
d'injustice.
La laïcité
n'est pas un principe
que l'on négocie.
L'altérité
n'est pas un sujet
sur lequel on tergiverse.
Le respect de l'autre, en politique,
qui ne pense pas comme soi
devrait être une exigence absolue
portée par chacun,
plutôt que de convoquer
systématiquement
l'excommunication,
l'insulte, l'injure,
en créant les conditions
d'une mise sous tension
du pays.
Le deuxième point, c'est qu'il faut
réconcilier la justice sociale
avec l'efficacité économique.
3e défi,
c'est le défi écologique.
Beaucoup d'entre nous
se sont battus
pour que la vie soit meilleure.
Mes enfants se battent
pour que la vie soit possible.
Ils ont 25-26 ans.
C'est ça, leur combat.
Comme ils se battent
pour que la vie soit possible,
il leur arrive
d'être en adhésion
avec les thèses
les plus radicales.
Si on ne donne pas
un débouché politique
à la radicalité,
nous aurons l'extrémisme.
Et le quatrième grand sujet,
c'est le multilatéralisme,
l'Europe et la paix.
Et dans le multilatéralisme,
l'Europe et la paix,
il y a l'universalisme,
il y a la défense
des langues qui portent
l'universalité,
il y a tous ces grands sujets
qui sont des sujets
qui renvoient à l'histoire,
à la grandeur,
aux valeurs, à l'âme
et à la culture des peuples.
-Vaste programme.
Merci, Bernard Cazeneuve.
Merci, Florence Delay.
Merci, Raphaël Gaillard.
Je voudrais rappeler
une brève bibliographie.
De Jean-Luc Barré,
une "Biographie intime",
de Jean Lacouture...
C'est des classiques.
A ces classiques
s'ajoute
le dernier ouvrage
de Bernard Cazeneuve,
"Ma vie avec Mauriac".
Florence Delay, je rappelle
que vous avez écrit
"Il n'y a pas de cheval
sur le chemin de Damas",
c'était votre dernier livre,
je crois.
-Mon avant-dernier.
-Et le dernier, c'est ?
-"Zigzag".
-Voilà, donc "Zigzag".
Raphaël Gaillard,
nous avons déjà eu l'occasion
de parler de
"Un coup de hache dans la tête",
que vous avez publié également
chez Gallimard.
Je voudrais vous renouveler
mes remerciements
pour cette émission
extrêmement intéressante
à laquelle, j'espère,
nous aurons l'occasion aussi
d'apporter des prolongements.
Je voudrais remercier
l'équipe de LCP.
Avant de nous quitter,
je vous laisse
avec cette citation...
concernant Mauriac :
"Il avait su rester
un homme libre.
"Il savait prendre parti
avec fracas.
"C'est curieux,
un catholique
"qui avait le sens de l'humour."
D'après vous, c'est de qui ?
C'est un acteur célèbre,
puisque vous dites
qu'on fait parler les morts :
Michel Simon.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA